foreign
across the northern border in Calgary
what's up Jim
hey how's it going good man how are you
I'm not too bad not too bad uh funny but
it's a cold day here today so that's so
good man uh hey can I just tell you your
accent brings me joy it makes me happy
I have an accent well I'm a Texan so
we're basically on the other side of
Earth and I get the same thing like man
we love your Texas accent I'm like I
don't have an accent I guess definitely
I do so yeah it's fantastic so hey so
what's up man
ah well
um I used to go I'm looking to try and
I've been trying to think of ways I've
been trying to
reconnect with my wife I have not been
able to I'm looking for ways to try and
reconnect with my life it's just
it's just been uh
just been going south for quite a long
time now it's uh we uh
we haven't really been all that close
we've been not basically roommates for
for years
um when's the last time you all had
sexual intimacy
probably over three years ago
wow
yeah
[Applause]
um
part of that part of that is uh that I
am basically Working Day and Night
literally like not even it's not
figurative it's literally like I drive
Courier Service uh from 10 at night till
five in the morning and then I work uh
and I work uh uh Construction in the
daytime until about up to four pm
sometimes 5 p.m go to sleep and so I'm
lucky to get a sport is a six hour sleep
a day a night whatever what what are you
what are you running from
what am I running from yeah uh
I don't know if I'm running from
anything maybe uh the bill collector but
that's about it I mean that's like are
you yeah are you running from Financial
insecurity are you in a season where
you're trying to earn a bunch of money
to get your guys solvent because you're
scared financially or have y'all created
I I I'd say that's accurate yeah that uh
yeah
um we uh we I've I've I'm self-employed
okay so uh
I read my own exterior business and uh
things were going quite well for for
quite a while there and we were doing
really good we were like and we were
just like a mom and pop
uh shop right uh sure we just do it all
on our own like I did a lot of it on my
own I I actually built up to about four
crews for a while and I was going good
for a while we were looking good and
then all of a sudden the recession hit
here in 2015 and everything just went
South all at once and
and uh yeah it's uh
just you know with the good graces of
God and friends that we were able to
hold on to our home and things like that
and it just you know and and I've been
uh like there's the people have been all
they've been saying you know why don't
you just go bankrupt it's like no I
I don't want to do that you know I I
they're my bills I want to pay them you
know that's that's Noble and good um
is that when your marriage took a turn
um
yeah it would be short right in that
right in around that time
um
there
there's a lot of uh geez oh God my if
you want to go back into my my past life
like it's it's like a
person would probably make a career on
me you know um
just with a lot of different uh a lot of
different things that have gone on in
the past uh are you talking about in the
past in your marriage
uh like I've had this is my third
marriage so
uh my my first marriage was just a
complete disaster a very young uh
very young uh wife got pregnant and I
wanted to be around my daughter and
so but that just fell apart within five
years and
then my second marriage my wife just
walked out so
um that that one didn't go very well and
then um it was a it was uh my wife now
and
and uh we've been together going on now
I said the 24 years now but we've only
been married uh nine so and she she's
she's left you too Jim
she stays she she left it too she stays
in the house with you
but y'all aren't married we're not even
in the same room you know so
so and part of part of what's going on
is that that I think uh what really
really hurts me is like I I I'm I'm
concerned about how this is affecting my
daughter like I'm sure she's not she's
not stupid but she she seems like a
happy child but I just don't know how
it's really affecting her right and like
uh she's my my daughter's like she's my
wife how old is she
12 12. so
your current wife isn't on the phone so
you're the only person I can talk to in
this in this relationship okay is that
fair yes
so if I look back to the last three
relationships you've been in there's
been one common denominator and that's
you
yeah well that's uh trust me that's uh
okay across my mind too all right so
your first one it just fell apart I
don't believe in that relational phrase
It's not that's not a true statement
things don't just fall apart
relationally people stop trying they
start putting their attention into other
things like building a business or
alcohol or still sleeping around or
whatever like they put their attention
other places
and not on the relationship and all like
if you stop changing the oil in your car
it doesn't just fall apart it quits
working because nobody took care of it
right and your second wife just left
right she just said I'm not doing this
your third wife has just parked right
she didn't fight she didn't flee she
just froze this is it this is the life I
got I'm moving into this bedroom and I'm
going to try to create a world where I
can survive inside of a pocket of
whatever chaos I live in or I'm going to
continue to be a mistress to all these
jobs
and imagine her
wondering man what is so unbeautiful and
unsexy about me what is so undesirable
about me that I'm second place to a
courier service
well actually
um
I don't do the two jobs by choice like
because I've uh
discussed with her on the number of
occasions where I don't want to be
working two jobs and because she doesn't
work okay she's she's days at home
um when shy uh when she was born
um
when my daughter was born she uh
we agreed that she was going to be a
stay-at-home mom
you know and I had no problem with that
things were good at the time you know um
business was going well and all that
um and uh I didn't have a problem with
that you know and we just we thought it
would be better for her to be home with
her mother instead of in daycare or
whatever right babysitters and stuff and
quite frankly my daughter has never had
a babysitter ever that's probably not
good because that means y'all have never
been on a date
no we haven't yes and she was born
that's not good that's a terrible
statistic my kids have had tons of
babysitters because me and their mom are
always going out
I have
tried that I have made suggestions to go
out uh anytime that we have gone out
it's
with our daughter okay so
um and I love her to death like uh
I totally believe that um there's no
question about that but you know there's
I've I've wanted to go out and and do
things like just us go out you know
uh like before before our daughter was
born you know we used to go out dance
and stuff we were
uh country western dancers here so
here's the deal you enjoyed that quite a
bit your wife
has a life has created a world
inside of your marriage that includes
her and her daughter and not you and
this is a pretty common thing that
happens
and
then you create a life financially that
you have to have and one of you just
keeps working and end jobs and doing
stuff because the data you've received
over the last 15 20 years is you're not
very good at relationships
and you love being a dad but she's just
better than you at it and so the one
thing you are good at is work
and so you say that's the best way I can
support and show my wife and my kid that
I love them is I'm just going to work
more and make sure their needs are taken
care of and there's some nobility to
that
but I promise you
you are working yourself in to an early
early death
oh I know I keep uh mentioning that like
like I said I have brought this up with
her and I've wanted to you know to quit
the night job because it's I
I mean here's here's how we bring this
up here's how we bring this up
um
we bring this up
you two
and I would push pretty hard for a
um babysitter
and I would push pretty hard for a
actually your kid's 12 now it's not
really a babysitter but somebody to come
over and keep your kid or let your kid
go play at somebody's house for a
weekend
and you and your wife are in desperate
need of some sort of retreat whether
it's four hours or half a day or a
whatever that looks like
do you have a history of yelling getting
fired up getting raged out
actually no it's on the other end okay
so your wife's got a history yeah I'm
usually the calm one and I'm usually uh
it's it uh wouldn't wouldn't it like I
don't even try to discuss things anymore
like I I basically am constantly just
walking away because
I I I
refuse to fight in front of my daughter
for one
I try I try my like I've I came from a
pretty uh pretty rotten uh family like
my family life was uh
pretty violent and abusive and uh and
and actually my wife came from something
similar to that as well uh from what she
tells me it was uh she was abused quite
a bit so uh
so here's here's what we get here when
we argue it it ends up into a screaming
match well I
I very rarely raise my voice like I I
get angry and I rarely raise my voice
and I I'll say things like
you don't need to yell and then she gets
really loud
exactly oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um coaching somebody on how they're
angry is usually not the best or the
best strategy
um it usually the best strategy in that
situation is later
to say Hey whenever we're having a
disagreement which everybody in the
relationship is going to have whenever
you raise your voice it reminds me of
being a kid and I shut down my body just
shuts itself down
and so it would be really a gift to me
if when we got into disagreement we
figured out a way to do that calmly or
we wrote each other notes or whatever as
we practice this
um
so earlier I said you were the common
denominator that goes one of two ways
the common denominator being you are the
guy that's really hard to be married
with and all these women are marrying
you and then they're like dude I'm out
of here out of here out of here or
you've heard the old saying that's
actually true we marry our unfinished
business
and it might be that you keep picking
the same partner over and over again
because your body has identified
relationships is something that's
abusive
yeah you know that has crossed my mind
too well and I and you have a little boy
inside of you wondering what it was so
bad about you that your mom talked
screamed at you like that and that Dad
beat the crap out of you whatever
happened and you have a little boy
that's constantly trying to solve it and
you tried it with wife number one and
you tried it with wife number two and
now you're trying it with wife number
three
and your wife's probably marrying her
unfinished business because you look
like a nice stable guy which is a
hundred percent different than what she
grew up with
the only problem is she does not have
the relational tools to be connected to
a calm quiet guy she has relational
tools for war
and you too have to decide I'm gonna
stop doing relationships as I've done
them my entire life and learn new skills
one of you you I'm going to speak up
more and I'm going to let my needs be
heard and I'm going to stop committing
long tail suicide in the form of working
20 hours a day for year after year after
year
and your wife's gonna have to learn
every relationship is not a battle in
fact there's a totally different reason
for relationships in its peace
and I've just never experienced that so
I'm gonna have to practice it and learn
it y'all are both gonna have to make
that choice or you're just going to have
divorce number three and if you're gonna
have divorce number three I'd recommend
sooner rather than later
but this this works with you telling her
I want to love you the best that I can
and I have
grown up with this and I want to do
something different would you be willing
to go with me
and that's going to look like me letting
my needs be heard me getting some sleep
and honoring my body me spending private
time with our relationship with my
daughter
us
rekindling Romance
you making some choices to to learn
different ways of communicating and not
fighting and going to war
because you're talking about two adults
deciding we're going to do everything
different from this point forward and
that's a tall ask it is a hundred
percent doable but both of you have to
be on the same page
I also know this brother
I I can feel it on you
that you think this is going to be a
futile conversation
yeah like I quite often I want to talk
about something and I just
I just figure what's the point all right
so here's what I want you to do you know
what's the point you you're worth the
point
your daughter's worth the point your
marriage is worth the point you still
love that lady your wife is worth it
that's what the point is that's the why
so if I'm you and I know I'm waving in
to you know the entrance to hell I am
going to write this down and write a
letter to to my wife and I'm going to
take her out I'm going to read it to her
and the letter is not going to be filled
with accusations you don't do this and
you don't do this and we haven't had sex
in three years and you don't it's not
going to be that
it's going to start with I miss my wife
I miss you
and I've participated in a marriage
where We've Ended up as roommates and I
miss you and I want to find our way back
to one another
I don't want to to raise a daughter who
thinks this is what marriage looks like
that is just roommates
I don't want to raise a daughter who
feels like she is responsible for Mom
and Dad's emotional well-being
that she's the center of our household
that everything revolves around her so
much so that my parents haven't had a
date in a decade
because of poor little meat because she
can't handle the weight of your
household she's 12.
so you say what's the point you are man
you get one shot at this little life
dude
so write it down have the hard
conversation and for the first time
maybe in a long time ask what you need
ask yourself what I need man
what am I willing to do what am I
willing to change what am I willing to
give
and ultimately the end of this
conversation with your wife is an
invitation are you willing to go on this
imitate on this journey with me
where we both learn new ways of
interacting we both heal from our
childhood that both of them are awful
I'm all in if you're all in and it's
going to be bumpy and hard we might have
to see a marriage counselor together
which I highly highly advise I don't
really see a way forward for you too
without it it'd be great
um
the point is you and your marriage and
your kid you're worth it man
let me know how that conversation goes
I'll be thinking about you because this
one's hard I know because it takes two
to tango man it takes two people to say
yes let's change everything
it only takes one person to say shut up
screw this
get up get get on with your life
and then you've got some really hard
choices to make
and I'll be with you along those roads
too man if that's where it ends up